so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
beauty there we go what's going on you
guys
gave me out of here back here back at it
with the attic show i got
hustle and motivate with me uh say
what's up hustle
hey how y'all doing man i got doing on
this fine uh
tuesday right uh yeah it is tuesday
isn't it i i
did they just get mixed up with me man i
don't know why they get mixed up
but today as you can see we'll be
talking about the playstation 5 in the
future of where that brand is going to
be going
probably the relatively new future it's
not a playstation look at that man i
talk about
playstation one time i got people in the
comic says shane it's a playstation
podcast
it is the attic show it's not anyone man
it's the attic show
so uh we're gonna be talking about you
know kind of mind hustles
predictions in terms of where the uh
the conference is gonna go we're also
gonna be talking about sequels because i
feel like
there's some bad things going on with
sequels that people have
like an expectation that's unrealistic
in a it kind of hard for developers to
me and we're gonna be talking about far
cry
6 and dying light too so
thanks for everyone for showing up you
know first off let's start with the fall
crying dying light
hustle you did say earlier that you
didn't see a whole lot of the the dying
light too
did you play the original dying light no
sir um
i wasn't even like into those types of
games to that type of game back then the
first person like the only first person
game that i really like got down with
was a little bit of doom halo mostly um
but i'm actually glad to see um
downlight 2 has some type of release
i don't know if it was a date was given
but some type of release window at the
very least because
as you remember addict uh that game was
on indefinite suspension like it was
like hold on we just want to stop
everything and um was it rumored that
microsoft were gonna we're gonna buy
them once upon a time and is that why
everything had ceased production or is
there something is another reason that i
don't think i can mention on your
platform
um there's a lot of things going on with
okay with them i don't necessarily think
that
maybe we'll see maybe we'll see like
some kind of game pass thing
for the most part i've always said when
it comes to like rumors
where there's smoke there's fire i don't
necessarily know
what happened behind closed doors i
don't know if they fixed it i don't know
if microsoft had anything to do with it
but i would be i wouldn't be surprised
if i saw like a game pass day and date
kind of deal or something like that
so you know uh i really enjoyed dying
light i thought dying light was
was it was a phenomenal game and i've
always felt like
it needed a sequel and i was kind of
like getting worried there for a minute
because it looked like you know maybe
this sequel ain't gonna come out and
live up to
uh what this game could actually be but
it looks like it looks great but it is a
crosston game and i think people are
getting this like weird concept that
crosston games have to look like they're
made for next-gen hardware but would you
agree with that
you know i really don't have an issue
with crosston
titles in general like the more people
who get to play a game
especially like that like the better in
my opinion um i keep hearing that you
know last gen stuff holds back current
gen hallway
and even if that is true just let's just
take it for what it is like yo more
people who can't get a
playstation 5 or xbox series x or s
because those things are hard to get
their hands on like the more people the
better
and um we're going to see a lot more
titles like that too i think um and i
guess we'll get to it later about the
playstation 5 stuff
it wouldn't surprise me that if horizons
is forbidden west
god of war two and you figure whatever
the next ps exclusive is
it wouldn't surprise me if all of those
across them because it's still very hard
to get a ps5
or xbox at this point that's my series x
at this point
yeah it definitely is because i i still
think we're gonna see
a lot of issues in terms of uh
production i don't think they're gonna
be able to fix that anytime soon
but i i what the biggest thing that i'm
just curious on is you know
what kind of scale wise this game is
going to be and you know we could
definitely bring up far cry 6 real quick
did you ever play the old far cries or
was it
you know something that kind of missed
you nah
it wasn't really my cup of tea like the
only thing that i remember about far cry
were the
villains how they put a big emphasis on
them so i just i was never really
interested
in those in particular um
okay and you can correct me from wrong
on this don't they like repeatedly use
like the same engine so
like if you've played them do the games
feel any different from like four five
and six
i know that they're different
protagonists and different antagonists
but do they feel any different
i think they look different but i don't
know if they feel any different i think
that might be
i think it's about the same you know
we can definitely you know bring up the
sequels of games
with this because i got an issue with
people and how they try to treat sequels
of games
my thing okay let's talk about halo okay
people want some unrealistic
expectation when it comes to well i
didn't like the previous ones i want
them to change the whole game to
to make me like it and i feel like that
is some
crazy thinking because it to me
if you didn't like the games you have no
you know
right to try to change the future of the
installments
it's just like maybe that game's not for
you i don't like gears as multiplayer
i've never liked gears as multiplayer
but do you see me campaigning for them
to change gears is multiplayer
hey i ain't from the holder i think you
might want to campaign to change
uh multiplayer you know as much as i
love gigs as much as i love games five
in particular
i think you might want to put a word
like boys is getting pretty bad but um
no no i i i feel you though but like
sometimes change is good because
here's what happens right like you
mentioned halo so let's let's talk about
halo for a minute
we got the bungee versions of halo and
now we got the 343 versions of halo now
you can speak to the multiplayer of that
side of things
is it even better has it gotten a lot
better at this point because i know a
lot of people make those comparisons
i love halo 3 and i think the sprinting
halo 4 while it's cool
i don't think it was necessary i just i
would have much rather just turn the
game up turn the game speed up a little
bit
i think that a lot of people try to
to put this this giant hill of hatred on
343.
look have they done a hundred percent
where i feel like
the playstation brand needs to be no i
mean not the playstation the halo brand
needs to be know
but we can't act like people's oh aim
down sights uh you know
sprinting like first off bungie put
sprinting in halo it was in reach so
you know we and second off a lot of the
people that work at fruit 343
was from bungie so it's just like look
like i get it
people don't like what they do but we
can't just see here and put blame on a
company that all they did
was take the work and go the direction
it was going i can almost guarantee you
a bungee never left microsoft
they would have went not me maybe not
necessarily the same direction
but they would have sooner or later
incorporated sprinting into the game
aim down sights because that's where the
evolution of the genre in general was
going
like how you expect people you know
these days
to you know to from a casual point to
to pick up the game if there's not even
sprinting in the game like
like i get it it slows down the gameplay
if people like it slow but it's just
like you are a s
you are a super human soldier and you
can't sprint
no i feel that it's just like you're a
super huge soldier you're supposed to
hit fire
i i understand like i understand people
wanting the game to evolve
but really where's the game going to
evolve like i
i think that people have took this
concept that god of war done
and they've tried to put that on every
game
what happened with god of war what cory
barlog did
as saint monica with god of war is not
normal that [ __ ] doesn't happen all the
time i was gonna say that that's a a
[ __ ] tall mountain to climb like that
that was indeed special like with with
corey and the team at sony santa monica
they're like yo
i don't hey listen it would be nice if
you know when games make those changes
like that it would be nice if all of
those games could hit that mark but
we're going to be realistic
man that's he's a special type of human
being uh
even turner franchise that was so
beloved you remember the whole thing was
like oh there's no jump button and it's
that in the third
people forgot about that real quick
didn't they yeah and see that
but to me god of war had had an
evolution they could have done
it kind of it wasn't necessarily 2d
i don't even know what kind of gameplay
that's technically called where it's
like
aiming above them a little bit because
that's what god of war was
like it wasn't behind like the old god
of wars was like
kind of like the the scream
tilted back why you fought in the world
you know what i'm saying like
and so they had a little bit of of a
work that they could do they could work
around that
like but to me people say they want
gears to change
where's gear's gonna go like to me it
sounds like you want another game
and and regardless i know that you and
eric are on your uh
anti-gears moment here recently like we
can't take away from the fact that you
guys ain't put mad hours in this game
yeah i got like 120 or 130 this was one
there's so
something some obscene number that i i
don't want to repeat but
yeah no i got you i got you i think i i
legit think i'm just tired of giving
that's what i feel like has happened
like it's not necessarily gears
multiplayer is a bad game because
it kept you guys in it long enough so
it's just you guys got tired of playing
and and i think there's a difference
between you know being tired of playing
a multiplayer than thinking something's
bad
and to me i just get tired of people i
know i put very little time in halo
trying to give their opinion on halo
yeah yeah i know well i had a guy to cut
you off yeah not
typically i got people in the squad who
who really
know what they talking about so i
typically keep quiet on those the only
thing i really wanted like
343 to fix was the story alleged story
issues were part five how they
hyped it up how it was gonna be you
versus lock and then it didn't really
turn into that like i kind of want them
to like be able to rebound
because apparently that the multiplayer
in halo 5 is really good
so if they got that down and they got
the story in the full good like
i think it's time for everybody to bring
it all together but we've heard you know
we've heard rumblings and rumors and
everything else since then
i just hope the team at 343 can get it
together and i'm gonna be honest with
you
i think after this even if they get it
together i think that they need a new
franchise i need to work on something
new creatively i feel like they're
getting burnt out i'm just gonna be
honest with you
i i i'd agree i i'd agree with you and
people in the in the chat
saying i'm gatekeeping like i'm kind of
curious what you mean by me gatekeeping
be feel free to you know uh tell me
exactly what you mean by me gatekeeping
because i i don't think me gatekeeping
i don't think me asking people that
don't normally play the franchise
and want the franchise to change is
gatekeeping
like the halo community is already at
war
enough we don't need outsiders telling
us what's good for the franchise
we've been playing for what two decades
like no
like i don't go i don't like 2k because
i don't like basketball i don't like
sports in general pretty much
you don't see me like let's make this
more attic way
like i want to play 2k but it's not
worthy of me playing
call of duty i don't play call of duty
you don't see me advocating trying to
have them change call of duty
i don't like gears i'm not sitting here
on twitter 24 7
arguing why gears needs to change their
multiplayer to get me to play
i just don't play those games you know
the thing about gears though in
particular
i think one of the main reasons why we
did stop playing it is because it is
kind of like super casualized i love gs5
but that's just
this is my first time playing it but you
get like assist kills now they made it
like super casual
and they kind of i mean
if you shoot someone to the brink of
death
and they kill them i don't you don't
think that you think
assisting getting assist skills is a
casual feature
hey it wasn't the number four from what
i understand now from but i understand
it wasn't in there before but but attic
is way more than that um
look we can go on a rant about the
coalition but
and i don't want to slam to the
coalition i just want to say this
if if i'm and i see eric in the chat
what up erica if me and erica are right
by each other we shoot each other
she lives with a 100 done to me and 99
percent done to her then it's time to
fix something dawg like yo something got
to get fixed over there um
like i said you could speak to halo a
lot more than me i just want them to
i just really want bonnie ross to like
make it her and the whole squad
because they've been through a hell of a
lot over the last five years and the
the budget was what 500 million
allegedly we don't know how much that
budget is
this is that's going to have to be
phenomenal i mean i don't think we've
ever
i don't think anyone's ever come openly
out and determine what the budgeting was
and i think the budgeting was the entire
time it was
because because halo 5 it's not like
they they made the game and
they launched it and they never messed
with it again uh if that was a budgeting
it was probably talking about the entire
time that they expected to support the
project
so i mean they developed it for what
three to five years and they and then
they supported it for another three
years so
i think it was that whole time including
the marketing like the marketing by
itself
was probably a couple hundred million
because people don't realize how
expensive marketing is it's
it's not cheap by any means and i think
that
you know in terms of the gears thing you
know like we could talk about frog car
because i don't think you could do it
about
dying light because dying light's just
the second one i don't think you could
really
go too much into that but far cry 6.
people say just looks like far cry i
want more
what do you want clearly it's selling so
there's
there's a prime example of people that
love the frog
franchise because i can assure you they
wouldn't keep making them if they
weren't making money
so it's like if the far cry people are
happy
maybe you're just not a far cry fan why
do you want to change far cry
when it's already doing well enough
like i just don't get that they changed
the scenario they changed the story
they changed the villain what what else
do they want do they want to add like a
third person
i think playstation has ruined this this
this community
oh boy to me it feels like everyone
wants their template and if they don't
get their damn template for story
related games it it needs to change
that's what i personally feel like
not every game needs to be a third
person action adventure game
i i think this one does as much as the
show the protagonist in the trailer
which i did see
shout out to merc 305 by the way i saw
that stream
and as much as they kept showing this
young lady like what's wrong with that
addict
look this dude's saying i'm
contradicting myself there's a
difference between me wanting to add
features
that are in every game such as sprinting
aim down sides of me wanting to change
the foundation that the game is made on
of like people act like they don't like
halo as a whole
so why are they wanting to change halo
that's my thing like i want aimed
outsides and stuff because i feel like
that is just the evolution of the
of the genre in general nothing to do
with halo
so to me i feel like you have to have
those features in there
to even really compete with anything but
i'm not asking people to take it out if
it's
if it's not in there it's not in there
if it isn't there it is in there i've
played them both
but i'm not going to sit here and act
like i don't want sprinting in a game
i really feel like the only people that
want sprinting in halo
is the people that can only use two
weapons the br and the handgun
because they know if you're extremely
good with those guns
sprinting takes the effectiveness of
those guns away
if you can sprint and change the motion
of the speed you have
you'll be less effective with those
weapons is that not true hustle
uh yeah hey i i had a question though
and don't you can't slam to the br
that's like a staple
no no i'm not slandering the br i'm
slandering
people i'm slandering people that want
sprinting
out of the game because i feel like they
can only use the br
and if you add sprinting in the game
those kind of features
hurt sprinting i mean hurt the br the ar
uh not the ar
but the br and the handcuff gun because
when you're
that's where halo jumping came in
because when you're out in the middle of
open of nowhere that's the only thing
you could do
there was no sprinting you had to jump
and fight back
and to me those people want sprinting
gun because that's the only guns they
could use
because they know that if they can
sprint
it's not just the same speed shooting
anymore
you could you could easily get out of
the way at that point
you could sprint straight for a door and
and thrust your way into that door
and if we were playing halo 2 you
wouldn't have that option they would
have just picked you off the br
[Music]
i have a question did they ever fix the
bloom
at a certain point the what uh the bloom
in a halo because apparently the og
halos they had something called bloom
and it was like when you aim you're not
really hitting people
did they fix the hit detection there's a
few things that that i want to know if
they fixed the yellow five
halo 5 they made it to where if you if
you shot someone aimed down sights it
shoots them out of it
so most of the time in the engagements
it was it was more beneficial for you to
shoot down sights anyway
and like i get it and then they made it
where if you run you don't regenerate
your shields automatically
so to me it feels like you know when it
comes to something like that
they're trying to make a middle ground
but people
i don't know why like i think we should
just
let halo die before we just keep
manipulating the foundation it's built
on
like clearly it's not going to appeal to
the
the masses that people want it to
and i personally feel like one of the
reasons that it was so dominant back in
the days because there was no
competition
call of duty was really its only
competition and it was
at that time i would say once you hit
like the the modern warfare 2 level
that's when it started raising above
halo so it's just like we didn't have no
fortnights and no war zones competing
with halo back in the day
um there is a halo god in the chat known
as eric empire
he said the only problem um that had
bloom and it was reach and that was the
one that i was trying to play recently i
was getting my airbus but i was
struggling with that one recently so
thank you very much eric hey um i don't
know man
i mean you you say a lot of people just
you know you say you wanted to dabble
are you sure you want a actual
franchise to death with some because it
sounded they could fix these with like
operations or whatever what's up the
thing is is
you know that halo 4 i felt like that
wasn't halo the multiplayer felt more
like call of duty
what i consider halo has nothing to do
with sprinting nothing to do with the
speed of the game nothing to do
it's map control that's what i feel like
halo is
and i felt like people constantly try to
change that foundation
it's like look like you don't everyone
starts the same thing you have to fight
for the weapons of the map
you have to fight for the sections of
the map
and you know when you look at
competitive halo
they let some of the weapons go because
they'll fight for a certain section of
the map to keep it
so they have to make a decision do i
want the shotgun or do i want the sword
because that's the side of the map i
need to lock down when [ __ ] gets bad
and i need to stop cussing my back
and it's just like i just personally
feel like
halo and gears is multiplayer
maybe not gears because i hear there's a
lot of issues with balancing and stuff
but
i don't play gears as multiplayer
because i don't like gears as
multiplayer so i don't i don't mess with
that
but i don't also don't see erica and you
in there
trying to evaluate trying to change
halo's multiplayer
because you guys don't play that's my
issue it's people putting the two
cents in something when they literally
don't play it at all
they'll put like maybe and then the
people that do play put
they play the campaign play a couple
matches of the halo multiplayer
and they're out and they're wanting to
change the stuff and it's just like
just stop you're not a fan like
you're you're you're a casual walk by
that plays it you don't
sit here and play it for for hours upon
hours in
i got like 10 days in halo 5.
so why would i care someone that's
playing halo
for five hours what they have to say
oh no that's that's big facts um i won't
go back to gears again but i think
that's kind of what was going on over
there when when we see
you know what never mind this ain't my
platform i was speaking on giz at
another day
as far as far cry 6 goes um you had
mentioned earlier right
one of the comparisons about it always
selling well and then always doing well
in terms of numbers and everything like
when you said that
the game that came to my mind was like
assassin's creed
a lot of people claim to like not like
it but it keeps coming out and it keeps
doing numbers
every single time it comes out um
like how do we stop this like because
like at a point
at a certain point do you think these
studios are becoming complacent it's
like oh
we're going to do our numbers anyway so
we can just throw it seems like we can
just throw whatever it's like the madden
syndrome we can just throw whatever we
want to throw up on there
people gonna buy it anyway i think
there's some of that going on but i
i think that another thing is people are
too scared to touch
you know what makes the franchises them
every time they do they get jumped on
and i think you got this this this
circle of cycle of hate
because it's just like do i change it
drastically because then
sure there might not be more
hardcore fans of this franchise than
their casuals and i might be able to
to appeal to them and get some more
people that doesn't really mess with my
franchise
or do i try to stick more to the
hardcore market but then i get no
casuals but the problem with that is if
you go to the casual market
you might mess up and not get none of
them and you've en ended up
isolating half of the hardcore market
and then vice versa so it's just like
what do you do it's it's a hard decision
to make
like do you want to try to make the
franchise
as best as possible or do you want to
try to pick it up
and keep it to the hardcore base because
at the end of the day
playing destiny and halo those casual
people ain't staying long
couple weeks a couple hours a day couple
weeks
tops when you play destiny that's what
happened to bungie
bungie was like let's make destiny you
know what we're gonna do with destiny
let's make it more casual destiny was in
the worst spot it ever was in destiny 2
because of that
and they ended up reversing all of that
it took them a while
but they did it and to me
sure you want to try to do stuff to
bring in more of an audience
but you never want to to spit in the
people that made you who you
are and i feel like there's too many of
that going on
final fantasy one of my favorite
franchises
and what's funny is final fantasy has
nothing to do with the other ones
it's literally for the most part you
know obviously there's certain sequels
but for the most part
it's a game that doesn't that that has a
sequel but it's nothing to do with the
previous ones
so you didn't really have to change that
you know
but then they started making live action
then you got 15 where it's
purely action they took the turn base
out which is
what pretty much their whole franchise
was built off of
yep it was a stable thing and now if you
look at it
they they're a show of their what their
former self was
you know people like the games i think
final fantasy 7 if
if i can't have turn based back i think
seven
was the best direction i could get but
at the end of the day was it
was it because i thought that the
fighting was was awesome or is it
because
of um of nostalgia for the final fantasy
7 story that kept me in it
i couldn't tell you i'm sorry i know
you're super big on that dream so
you would have to actually explain that
to me see i'm i'm an old man at it just
in case you didn't know
i remember final fantasy one through at
least
seven being turn-based i'm not sure
about eight nine to ten but when did
they make the move to go to um
action rpg instead of turn-based rpg
well
to my knowledge final fantasy 12 was the
first one they've really started
dabbling in it
and it wasn't necessarily like it still
kind of was turn-based well it wasn't
turn base
but then they went to 13 and that was a
little bit
uh that was that was more turn-based
than anything else and then they
switched it went to 14 which was an
online
and then 15 is when they went straight
into it now i didn't like 13. i think 13
was
definitely the worst in the franchise
and i had to live with that for like
eight years because they had
two sequels of 13.
so 15 i felt like was a direction a
little bit better in the right direction
what wasn't necessarily where i wanted
to be but it was better than where it
was
uh talk for one second yes sir
so i think when you drop over 15 like
sequels i i think at a point
you got to switch it up at some point
and it really could be a shot in the arm
if you look at something like
the yakuza series right if you look at
these yakuza series now apparently it's
so much
it came with that much needed shot on by
going turn-based as we oh and i'm
talking about i can't imagine how
mad the bass fans are for for
yakuza imagine playing yakuza for this
many years
and they're like we don't care we're
changing it i like it because i like the
turn base but
as i was about to say i don't hear them
no i don't hear them at all well
we'll hear them man and you know but not
but i was saying as you stepped away
like you'll just imagine doing something
over
let's just say over 15 times with final
fantasy don't you think you gotta switch
it up well at one point
at some point you gotta be like all
right let's try something else my thing
is you have companies
that are still doing turn based doing
fine dragon quest there's there's a mode
in there you can make a turn base
persona is probably one of the most
successful games this generation
in its turn base i mean yakuza just went
to turn base so clearly there's a huge
demographic of people and it's been
extremely successful but final fantasy
want to keep trying to do
do new stuff and and it's a hit and miss
well you know persona persona strikers
is a it's like uh i wasn't talking about
i guess
well i know i just i didn't want to
serve clarifications purposes
they're like uh what's that like dynasty
warriors so they switched it up a little
bit but
no i i feel you though i feel you i mean
you know when
yeah but i just like look this is always
like speak from terms of the creator
right
you don't want to get stagnant because
when you get stagnant you become unhappy
so let me ask you this then yes uh i
beat octopod traveler by the way someone
in the comments section talked about
oxford travel
all right so let's let's talk about
gears 5 for a minute because i know
you're a fan of that
base game gears 5 did you like it
do you mean this the campaign the
campaign i have not played the campaign
i am playing the campaign hold on eric i
need you to get up in here man i'm going
to send you an invite i need you i can
hear erica
you get erica because i actually want to
run that co-op
but one of the issues that i actually am
having is that
apparently it used to be four players in
co-op but then they switched it to three
and it's not even three it's really like
two and a half because there's two
people who can play
and then there's jack i think i saw you
and smooth playing it like who gonna be
the robot though
come on man i actually like being a
robot oh my god oh my god
for the whole game yeah what'd you play
hold on but you probably played and beat
it
uh beat the game on your own more than
likely right no i don't think i've ever
beat that again by myself
it's like oh no oh geez so you just
electrocuted people picked up the
weapons to open doors
dude without a good jack that game got
really
annoying like on the real like without a
good jack
that game was mad annoying you know to
me
you know i got to get eric in here first
if she comes in here that's why
okay it could only be for a minute
that's fine i
just got to talk to you about this gears
thing you know this scares me
i feel like in terms of gears
i actually like besides act three i felt
like act 3 was the weakest by far
i felt like the game was awesome act one
was it was great act two was great
act three was the weakest and act four
was just was was great
uh act two that's where you saw in the
trailers with kate going through the
snow and stuff
i thought that was the hot that was the
height of the franchise
well not the franchise but you get what
i'm saying but i can't remember
of what was going on there so but i see
a lot of people
saying that gears 5 was underwhelming
and i'm like
where sure act 3 was
wasn't the greatest but act 1 2 and 4
was great
so i'm just like where is this energy
saying that this game was underwhelming
go erica sorry i just got here so i
can't be here long
okay that's fine okay what are we
talking about did you okay you played
gears 5's campaign right
yes did you like it it was it was good
it wasn't amazing it was good did you
play hive busters
yes did you like you yes yes okay
now do you still feel like gears needs
to move
like do you need gears like the story
needs to evolve
well they're gonna have to finish up
kate's story so even if
even if we wanted to like gear six is
gonna have to finish it so i don't see
how
they could even do that honestly like i
used to think i wanted gears to change
you know you see god of war you see what
they did over there and stuff like that
i used to think oh that would be cool
but but the more i think about it like
the more i i don't want that
gear it's like i said earlier in the
show god of war is not something that
happens
every time god of war is a phenomenon
someone in the chat named me something
drastic that changed like god of war
because i can't name anymore that
changed drastically
like the like like god of war three did
to god of war 2018 because i cannot tell
you one
they're gonna have to fix whatever that
well no not whatever the issue was
there's a decision that you're faced
with
in gears five with two of the main
characters i mean they're gonna have to
figure out like the actual
stories one of the one of those stories
is gonna have to be canon at that point
they they can easily get away right away
on that multiple time multiple ways they
could have a scenario where because at
the end of the day unless they do
drastic changes to who you
who i mean at this point look so
someone dies at the end i ain't going to
tell you what this kind of decision is i
i can't explain it unless i say it
look it it's easy for them to do
multiple different cut scenes for the
same scenario just
the other person's dead or not dead it
might change the
the dialogue a little bit like i think
they're probably going to choose one to
be the canon one not to be the canon but
at the end of the day like i don't know
where they're going with that and i i
think people give that
a little bit too much of an attack as
well because it's like
you don't know what they're doing with
it and i see
all types of people acting like they
know exactly what they're gonna do with
it
so it's just like we gotta wait we gotta
wait for how gear six is gonna turn out
for all we know they could be making a
mass effect way where
your decision of that particular part
changes the whole scenario
in gears but if if you look at it
at the end of gears 5 they had scenarios
where it did change the overall outcome
to me why would they put that much
effort they weren't going to care
what happened at the end of that game
yeah i think people just assume
they just ask the question what are they
going to do what are they going to do i
haven't even thought about it to be
honest
i haven't even thought about it it's
like that's true they could
they could uh surprise us and do like a
mass effect type i mean other games have
done it
really you're playing as kate so kate's
going to be there
it's just whoever's in your party is
going to be switched out if anything
it's amazing
there's going to be some cutscenes with
them and without them so i mean it's not
super far-fetched to think like oh they
can't pull it off
it's it's possible i didn't say that
they couldn't it's just gonna be crazy
to see how they do it like it's
i'm more interested in that i can't wait
to like hey erica at some point we're
gonna have to run the gs5 uh campaign
you know for me so you can carry me
through but
i'm looking forward to it already hustle
you on your own i know
uh well done thank you for your support
i
appreciate you when i see people say
well it's more gears
i hate that damn statement it's more
gears it's more halo
like you don't hear me saying it's more
unchartered
i mean that's what they're saying about
horizon right now more hurricane
but my point is just like how do you
what do people expect
like when i saw what i saw and forbidden
whatever it's called forbidden woods
from west like forbidding
like to me when i see that it just it
looked like
horizon done better like like i just
don't get where people
want like i don't get like what's crazy
and what's hilarious is you talk to
people they say gears 5 was
underwhelming
gears 5 was they it was just more gears
they needed to do something different
then you talked to people about the same
people you talked to them about
about um what's the one i just brought
up the the little expansion they did
but i have busted this which was
phenomenal yo
how did you feel about hive busters it
was amazing
tell me how high buster's more like
gears one through three than gears 5 is
so tell me how you said six months ago
that gears needs to change
and they give you an expansion that's
more like the old gears
than this gears but gears didn't change
so now
i'm confused what you want because
you're telling me you wanted to change
and they give you what the old stuff
used to be redefined and made it look
nice
and now you're saying gears isn't a good
place i'm confused
i think they just don't know what they
want until it's in their hands like
did they when they said they wanted
gears to change did they say to go back
to the original or is it like no we want
something i don't think they know
differently
that's what i'm saying i don't think
they know like at least when i tell you
if i did want like the multiplayer of
halo i think
isn't a good place from halo 5. i don't
care what none of you in the chat think
this is me
attic show i can have my own world you
can't do [ __ ] about it
no language language sir it is what it
is so
i would personally like to campaign to
change though
i don't want i want a linear campaign i
want something like wolfenstein
for a campaign no halo oh halo am i done
i want set pieces for halo i i want i
feel like that's the better way for for
a multipla
for for a halo single player because
because like you go on wolfenstein
people remember like going through with
the wheelchair you know what i'm saying
like
like stuff like that was good so i want
stuff like that for a halo
single player and i'm and at least when
i say i want something to change i give
you a scenario where i want to change
you ask how you want halo to shame i
don't know how you want gears change i
don't know
how you want far cry to change i don't
know like then why do you keep talking
about
it like sure gear six and not gear six
far cry 6 looks exactly like far cry
5 4 and 3 but guess what
the people who bought three four and
five loved it enough to where they felt
like they needed to make a six
so who am i to tell them to change far
cry
because clearly there's enough people
buying that i'll just go play something
else
people act like they ain't games out in
these streets
everyone you know like uh
like they just don't really know what
they want i think that's that's what it
comes down to and really addict like
you're right you said this earlier i was
listening i was in the chat
a lot of these people don't even play
these games like the gears
were complaints i'm like well have you
been in these games have you played them
are you gonna play it probably not a lot
of these dudes
so i i just paid no mind i think it's
it's irritating because it's like we've
been i've been there
for over 10 years already playing gears
for so long and it's like who are you to
just come in
and and i know somebody in the chat was
like that's gatekeeping no it's not if
you're not going to play the game
who are you to say you're going to want
to change when the die-hards
it's not gay because i'm not i'm not
telling you you can't play the game
you could go easily just go get that
game just as easy as i can
i'm telling you if you're not a fan of
the game you got no right
to talk down on my opinion of the game
because you have zero experience in it
and
that's what i agree with you i agree
with you on that and i'll even take it a
step further um certain people who and
i'm not gonna mention any names of
course but certain people who may have
influence who aren't familiar with the
series
they have to be careful too because
their word would hold more weight than
mine or like america's or eric empires
or mercury
it would just hold more weight so like
you would have to be careful in that
instance as well
um as far as the gas thing this is this
is the exact reason why i'm going
back and i bought um i bought is one on
a game pad so this is exactly the reason
why i'm going back so i really want to
see what the differences are between
epic's version and the coalition's
version i want to see because i know
what i fell in love with
from playing i played a little bit of
the original gears
uh i didn't play a whole lot of it but
again plus they're outdated now i don't
want to go back to them
i played the first one i played a little
the second one and i played a little the
third one but i never
beat the second and third one like i
enjoyed what they've done with gears
four and five i actually feel like
coalition has
had xbox on they back the whole xbox one
generation
they did like they were doing more than
any of the other studios were doing they
were they they were
nine times out of ten always up there in
some form of game you had
gears ultimate then you had gears four
then you had gears five
then you had the um i keep forgetting
that tactics
your tactics because they they
co-developed that i i would say
they had a little bit less hands-on but
they still helped with in some form of
fashion
and then they had hive busters look at
all of that
they've done a lot with the brand and
obviously i think
there was a little bit of weird
messaging i don't know if they initially
wanted kate to be the main character
from the fourth one i think they kind of
thought the process was but
like you could tell that they if you
play the game the game's about kate
years four is about kate so i don't
understand why people are confused
when gears 5 was kate yeah
i was confused by that too it's like how
do you not if you played the fourth game
why are you surprised kate is the main
character like the
the cliffhanger was literally for kate
i think it was because they let you play
as jd so people assume that you was
going to play jd
and i think the reason they let you play
as jd is because they don't want to
they don't want to ruin what the story
is going to be about
they wanted to to capitalize on that
your main character from the original
trilogy son
and they can't really go into that with
kate because you can't know who her
parents are at the time
mm-hmm real quick carlos
alvarado he says he has a two dollar
super chat
halo will have set pieces and open world
elements we'll see i've
i think 343 has the capabilities of
making a great halo because they made
sections of
great halos like i think they've made
good halos they've never made a good
like a great amazing halo and i think
that's the issue
people wanted amazing hail including
myself we don't want half a product and
we spent
60 70 dollars i don't know how much
these games are gonna be
we we didn't spend that money for half a
product we want the whole product
so i think that's the issue and gears i
personally feel like they're taking
gears in a good direction
i love the campaign of halo 5. i mean
gears 5.
i thought you know besides act 3
gears was a great game gears 5 was a
great game
the open world stuff you talking about
yeah i don't even necessarily like the
open world stuff i just think act 3
was a lie act two i forget act one
was when you fought your way out of the
city act two is when you was in the i uh
was in the
the mountains with the snow yeah act
three was when he was in the desert
the desert right and act four is when he
was doing that last like
war thing so like i personally felt like
besides act three and act three wasn't
horrible it was just
compared to act two it was it was bad
yeah i agree with that and i can't sit
here and say
gears 5 was underwhelming or a bad game
or even an average game
when i i i enjoyed every ounce of that
game but
maybe three or four hours and
that might even be pushing i don't you
think it i don't feel like
i think just the fact like me listening
to you knowing you didn't really
go through the whole original trilogy
like you played what one of them you
beat one of them played the other two
didn't beat them like hearing this from
you now is kind of
bridging the gap it feels like maybe
coalition did a decent job because you
liked the game
i thought it was good i thought gears 5
was good
so obviously they did something right
there there's something in there
you know i didn't i didn't i didn't have
an issue with gears 4 but i definitely
didn't like
i played gears 5 and almost damn near
one setting it might have been two or
three but it was down
it felt like once like because
i me and kit had it like three or four
days before it came out before it
started bugging out and stuff
so like we pretty much was throughout
the whole game before the game came out
so like to me i feel like you guys are
talking from a nostalgia standpoint
from the first three wouldn't it well
like me personally when it comes to the
new gears i have issues with it
multiplayer wise even single player i
feel like the
like attentions to details and things
like that the the goriness the horror
elements of it those are kind of they've
been lost in a way
and coalition's kind of doing a
different
i don't want to say art style because
it's still gears but it's like it's much
more colorful it's much more bright it's
much more
like it's just the tone of it is a bit
different the characters obviously i
feel like the older character is
way better yeah so there's issues in
there but as far as like
what they've done well with us pacing
and and
how quick the characters move now and
things there are things that are good
and better now
it's just we hold on to that nostalgia
of like the characters you know what it
could be too
what i've seen from you know from
playing the first one and playing a lot
of the second third one is
i think in the original gears trilogy
it always felt like at any time there
was something on the line
like someone could die at any time every
game you you
you know you expected this is war people
die
any one of your peoples can die at any
time and i don't feel like you get that
in the new gears
like you feel like when you play a game
you're in a war but you're not an award
you know what i'm saying that's why
when there was a certain character that
looked like they died in five
at the very end in the robot i know i'm
sure you know what i'm talking about
it kind of gave a little bit more of
that oh we in a war
but then not even 30 minutes later they
reversed that he didn't die
like it's just like i i do feel like
yeah
in gears it always felt like there was
something on the line you was in war
and at any time one of your favorite
characters it's kind of like the the
season finale in the walking dead
but i don't feel like they have that in
the newport news it felt much more
dire back then like you know and then
when somebody did go
you felt it you got emotional you felt
it like for that character even though
they're not
the most complex characters they're kind
of like these dude bro
dudes but you still felt something now
it's like
like years five for example you're like
eh okay that happened
moving on about the erica i think that
yeah i think that's why a lot of people
don't like the decision at the end of
gears 5 because
they finally gave you a scenario where
someone's going to die
and they let you choose who's going to
die so it's just like
they should have just killed someone if
they're not going to do it correctly i
don't know what they're going to do
so they should have just killed some so
carlos did another two dollar super chat
love to see gears in more of a horror
setting that's what erica was saying
earlier yeah
that's what i missed i missed that stuff
don't put in the first person shout out
to jess corden but don't put him in
first person yeah i heard when he when
he said
i'm saying that uh jess cordon over
there at xbox uh too
i mean that's what i feel like what i
said but the thing is when i see people
constantly saying we want to change we
want to change we want to change
and they put an open world element in
the game and they still are not happy
with that
and but they like height busters but do
you want it first person because that's
what i'm thinking at this point
no no no no no no does that dude even
play gears like that
anybody's good
i actually would like coalition to
to make a third person cover halo game
in the halo universe
that would be cool maybe i'd play it
maybe they could have made a spartan
lock
one where he's becoming a spartan and
he's still
par part of the open but it is what it
is
did you i got to head out though thanks
for yeah thanks for inviting me on it
was fun to talk to you guys
catch you guys so we're gonna talk about
this playstations thing real quick uh
uh oh let's go so clearly as you can see
there's rumors that it's gonna be in the
end of july i don't think that's
necessary i don't know what's going to
happen
that seems a little late i don't think i
mean they might wait that late but i
feel like they're still going to want to
capitalize in some form away from e3
but waiting all the way in july i think
that that's gone
at that point now let's go into this
what is your expectations for whatever
their showcase is
okay my expected they're gonna kill it
um if if history shows us anything right
we can go based off of the last in that
state of play but with the last like
big event that they did before the
playstation dropped how they showcased a
bunch of different games
um we just heard recently that there are
25 new ips in development of course we
may not hear anything from them
but papa but i expect greatness uh every
time playstation drops if this event
does happen in july
we'll see something in reference to
kenna um hey addict
we'll probably see some people really
want to see kenna again
oh let's not do that oh cool we can't do
that at it come on that's kind of
i think hey look it's going to happen i
don't think people want to see kenneth
again
we gotta we got a two dollar super chat
from carlos love to see a
halo flood escape mode with a squad that
would be interesting
they should have actually probably
collaborated and made that in gears that
would have been cool
but continue yeah oh for sure for show
um
okay so we'll see that more than likely
if i had expectatio
expectations or predictions
horizons for obama said zerada horizon
forbidden west
will more than likely have a release
date and i say that if they show it
again they're going to have a release
date because they wanted to stay in the
news cycle i didn't mention that
on the last little appearance i made
excuse me
i'm not going down you added got
promised i promise um
just keep going just kick you from the
thing i don't know what's going on with
him
as far as expectations okay so we
haven't heard anything about um
gran turismo have we i know we saw it
like last year
but then they said it was delayed okay
so i think it's a counter punch the
forts of which
it may be rumored to come out this year
later on this year it's coming there's
no rumor it's coming
okay all right i almost might speak
mediterranean so i think five is
definitely coming this year
oh so with horizon five coming this year
i think we see something about uh gran
turismo
at some point i think sony has to uh
counteract that um
so sony has a history of showing things
like way in the
way in the future way way way way way in
the future right a lot of people give
them
give them crap for it i think we see
something in regards to uncharted 5.
and at that end i see nadine
i see chloe and i see sam in there it's
not going to pick up with nathan's uh
daughter i know a lot of people may want
it to but i don't think it's going to i
think they're going to i hope that
i hope not at the end of the day that
they wouldn't have made that
that little pro that little part at the
end of
uncharted 4. they have no intentions on
carrying that i think if anything you'll
see
them kind of like mentor her
i think that's probably going to be the
mo the realistic scenario
but then again you know lost legacy it
didn't flop by any means so you know
maybe they open their eyes a little bit
more on
you know maybe we can bring these
characters in a little bit more but it's
like i said i think if they are in there
it's going to be her mentors like
something's going to happen where
you know drake's dead or something like
that or
and she going to be a grown-ass woman at
that point
and you know she knows what her dad did
but i don't think she knows to a point
where her dad did you know what i'm
saying
and they gonna show up and like
something's going on and maybe someone
killed drake and you're trying to figure
out what
why why maybe he's missing maybe they're
gonna pull last of us i don't know
like like well well this is on charter
addict
they don't get that dark in particular
um
shout out to naughty dog they'll do that
with the last of us for sure for sure
but uh
uncharted in particular is super i don't
know so are we saying the charter needs
to be the same
no oh not at all you're saying they
don't normally do that so that means
they need to be the same
i'm saying that it is great that
uncharted has its own lane
i do not want that joint to get like the
last of us dog i get the crown left and
right i can't i can't deal with that
chloe phrase is my first i can bring the
chat chloe fraser is my
favorite single player uh protagonist
from last year
that's that's baby that's my baby what
yeah no but they don't need to get that
dog um
if they do bring up nathan drake's
daughter that will be dope and i would
love how that kind of intertwines
what happens if they bring what happens
if
medina them are the main characters
nathan drake's daughter ends up being a
villain
[Laughter]
that would be a crazy twist man that'd
be a crazy twist
i would love to see how uh naughty dog
writes that out i would love this like i
want that perspective that would be a
dope little thing because
she getting body i'm using they did i'm
using sam on me like
can you imagine if sam got a like killer
his niece
yeah that'd be crazy
this is not this this this on just the
uncharted series yeah i expect for that
joint to be goofy
whims are cool i mean yeah sure he may
have some heart warming touching pauses
in there but
nothing crazy it won't be nice it
probably won't so okay so we're
on charter five we are on
uh you think that we'll see gran turismo
yes what else
uh god of war ii oh god of war two
excuse me god of war
ragnarok i don't think we necessarily
get a title i think we see like another
splash screen and a year release
if if i'm speculating of course
if horizon forbidden west does come out
this year it probably won't but if it
does
then we'll see the other one drop
because god of war is normally dropping
in march
you can correct me on that but um i know
the last one for sure dropped in march
than that i don't know i'll have to look
that up
okay so if yeah well
i can tell you for sure if not much
it'll be in the fall um so that'll be
their big title
uh it released on april the 20th it
might have got delayed that might be an
old release date
i think i think it was april though i
don't know it might have been a little
later than that
all right so you think we're going to
see god of war we're going to see
uncharted 5
grant thrisma we might get a release
date for horizon anything else
um i want to get you i want to hit you
with like some type of wild crazy
prediction
um the people who make the order the
order 1886 are no longer around because
they think they got acquired by facebook
so
we won't see anything from them um
i'm going to sound crazy in saying this
but you remember those leaked documents
that just came out about uncharted
4 going to pc
i literally think that we see something
in regards to that
about uncharted having more life in
terms of multiplayer
so i think i think we do see something
about that
so do you think we see anything from
like sucker punch or insomniac
insomniac nothing new it'll probably
just be like hey here's ratchet and
clank
um have many people wrote it here's some
more gameplay
they probably because if this is rumored
to be next month they probably won't
announce in the dlc they'll be like hey
just go play where we just dropped
um sucker punch
has ghost has ghost got any dlc outside
of that multiplayer has ghosts
i think they they might show up before
sucker punch dlc
so okay let's say because i think that's
realistic i don't think that's like
crazy
so they show up for fun charter five not
necessarily a new ip but a well
uh loved franchise grand trizmo
release date uh
probably you know what probably not i
think they i think they're sure just to
be like hey we're the king
we you know we see forza doing anything
but we we the kings around here
and if it is a release date it'll be
next year
look i think i'm gonna let that king's
thing slide until they show their kings
oh where we're gonna go with that
because until they start coming out
there and they start hitting that note
that the wave fours has been doing it
you know you can't hide and claim you're
still a king
how many times can can a ufc champion
deny
a a contender fight and then still claim
he's the king he'll get that belt yank
from him so you know
um horizon you think it comes out this
year
i think that there will be an announce a
release date
announced this year and okay so part of
me
part of me wants to say this playstation
games don't typically release in
november because of uh
what's that call of duty call of duty
pardon me in a battlefield
you know games like that right and
typically november's around
microsoft's time i think if it is
announced it'll be announced in either
september or october
like i said i think that i really think
they're just doing the rollout because
that game damn it looked dumb when we
was looking at it we're being real um
but i think they just want to roll up to
stay in the news site
i mean they showed us anthem and that
that that definitely wasn't done
so they they can definitely
they can definitely finesse you with
these these vertical slices
there's no denying that good point
i think
i think sony's gonna stay safe i don't
think they're gonna really go
out of their comfort zone too too much i
think horizon's coming out in 2022
i don't think there's any reason to do
that state of play last week
if they were going to have this year uh
because
are you just going to redo another state
of play like are you going to reshow the
same gameplay for
for for e3 if you aren't going to show
the same gameplay are you going to
show new gameplay that takes time so you
you had the studio make two different
kinds of gameplay
i think they got it in the tuck and now
and even if they don't show the gameplay
if they do show it again they're going
to show that release date
i can't like i said i think they're
doing this for a news cycle thing
i think hey we got everybody talking and
we got the weirdo i was talking about
but let's fix ayla to stand in the third
i think they come back again you know
they drop you know xbox to drop that
guard after e3 because
something's been known to do this or
playstation's been known to do this when
the xbox dropped they got
you know sony come back playstation come
right back with that right hook
and knock them out and we've seen it
time and time again so it wouldn't
surprise me it definitely wouldn't
surprise me
i feel like they're going to go ahead
and probably if it's not announced to e3
which
i don't think it's going to because to
me two weeks is is
is is not enough time to justify
delaying something
like if they had the news well was it
last tuesday or wednesday or thursday it
was wednesday wasn't it
if they had news wednesday they could
have easily just held it to the next
event
so to me they're not going to show it to
e3
it's going to be one of those things
where they're just going to announce it
on twitter that's been delayed
because i just don't see them doing all
of that work
to still come out and say it's coming
out this year
like they already did that event are you
like i said like why not just say it
there unless they don't know if it's
coming out this year
and 9 times out of 10 if people don't
know what's coming out this year
they are hoping for the best and that's
why i don't want to commit to anything
because i just don't see why you would
hold that information
there's no reason to like you got plenty
of stuff
you got god of war got whatever uh
sucker punch is working on you got
plenty of stuff you don't have to hold
anything back
unless you don't know and in that case
if you don't know there's a good chance
it's probably not coming out this year
in general
uh they got butchered over the the last
of us thing where they had to keep
delaying the game because of covid
so you know and i was told a couple
months ago that
it was delayed 2022. no eddie
i didn't bring it up but uh the last of
us part two
um remember how they said they weren't
gonna work on any dlc but they had sold
so many copies at that
point like they would be stupid natsu
they definitely said they weren't going
to work on a part three
i think we get abby dlc we'll probably
get live dlc or something like that
um or one of the other character side
characters dlc i think we
i think we get doc for the last of us
part two
that's that's uh it might be it might be
it might be i know you know so
kenny howard said where's xbox for elite
dates
this sunday iop because i didn't want to
do my
my predictions with a new panel until
iop and we did ours
so this sunday we're doing a prediction
show for iop i'm not allowed to tell the
guests
unfortunately so after that
tuesday next tuesday we'll be doing one
on the attic show
with a completely different panel won't
be the same panel
so come there because i'm sure you can
appreciate that
i understand xbox's stuff is is
i'm not gonna go into it you know what
kenny not doing i'm not following your
trap
all right if you want to know that stuff
come in next tuesday at 5 pm
ladies and gentlemen there are 88 people
in here right now and we have 56 likes
can we please hit the like button man
let's get more eyes on this
shout out to you eric i'm super proud of
what y'all doing over there especially
you got your own little platform on the
monday and tuesdays and all that man
you're doing your thing
you're doing your thing i love it i love
it yeah
okay got stuff i gotta get handled too
but you know definitely like i said
we we we might have a big guest on
sunday we might
so you know i definitely want you know
that's my personal opinion when it comes
to it
i personally feel like playstation is
going to play it safe
they're going to maybe release one or
two big announcements and not
necessarily like massive announcements
but i think they're running to the same
issue that microsoft's running into
they they don't want to show all their
their cards because they can't sell any
more consoles than they have
that's true so why do stuff like that
when it's not going to lead to more
sales
and i think sony's having the same
thought process like
they know they're gonna they're probably
trying to do as much as they can to make
as much for the holiday sales
but at the end of the day they know they
don't have
they they know they don't have a huge
amount of stock to sell so they're
trying their hardest to keep
that realistic and just to show
everything is is naive you're never
going to get anything from it
i do think we'll see some maybe some
gameplay from god of war
i think there's a chance for that
because god of war
supposedly is coming out this year i
don't think they've delayed it
officially yet
it's that that is nah
listen listen i know with what they said
that's getting the delay dog like that
that'd be crazy to even
try to release that this year unless
unless it's like a i know
king he likes to joke and says miles
morales is like the dlc for spider-man
and all that
right if it's something like of that
stature which i doubt but if it's
something that stashes then i get it but
i still
wouldn't release it this year do you
think do you if they did
if it was like a miles thing and it was
a smaller game
how upset do you think people would be
oh boy i'm gonna be on twitter that day
that's for damn sure but
i mean for me like if these stuff like
that don't really bother me man but
i'm not going to lie though i haven't
like four hours in
garden world 2018 it is hitting a little
different i can understand why a lot of
people love that game man like it was
it's one of the best experiences that
i've ever played i just jumped from game
to game to game the game like a
like a madman but it's it's going to hit
for something else i think god of war 3
is still the better game
hey i have not played god of war three
yet i think you're not the only person
who says that though
god of war 18 i'm not one of those
people that think god or 18 is bad
i think it's a great game it was
probably one of the best games made last
generation
but as far as like god of war
i think god of war 3 just had some of
the best pacing i've ever seen in video
games
so you can't beat that and then not to
mention there were issues with god of
war
2018 fighting the same troll over and
over again
i felt like the camera angle became an
issue at some points not every time but
there were issues where i was having
with the camera angle
especially fighting the valkyries where
they would just disappear and reappear
on the map
sometimes i couldn't find them because
of the camera angle but it is what it is
but
any last now any last
predictions that is realistic because
i'm about to hit you with the
give me that mic drop moment that's why
i want you to hit me with that
well predictions that i think are
realistic i typed in the chat but uh
we get a release date for straight
because uh the game with the cat
and the ray tracing and then the lights
and the highlights and all that we get
up
we get a release date for that um
because they said that was supposed to
release in 2021 as well so we get a
release date for that
mic drop moments i would like to say to
my mic drop moment
oh no i got it bg be proud of me for
this one they announced factions too
i don't think that's a mic drop moment i
think that i think people expect that at
this point
oh i added people expected but okay
let's be real it ain't happening yet
it has not happened yet bg is leading
the charge he is on neil druckmann's
back i mean i mean let me curse only but
no no i think i think we get that and i
think we get a release date
i think we get a release date for
fashions too there we go i think my mic
drop moment
is final fantasy 7 remake 2.
oh the second part
[Music]
because i think we all know that what's
going on right now it's not supposed to
be
a long-term thing uh so any mother mike
drop moments from me before we close out
of here
um see outside of the
outside of that uh
oh this is a shot in the dark like hell
um another dog announces that new ip
that they're going to be working on well
i don't think we get no gameplay i just
think we get like a metroid prime full
of splash screen type thing
so we got another two dollar subscribe
from carlos thoughts on the
necromonia higher gun number two steam
sales
i definitely butchered that i think kid
smooth was playing that on xbox
i haven't played it yet so you know me
and his shirt digital library so i might
boot it up but i usually try to stay
away from something against kid be
playing because he'd be trying to
achieve and hunt and i don't care
because he'd be playing some suspect
stuff for those achievements man
he played a dome right on my parade
which i'm not going to slander him for
but
if he like it i love it i guess
yeah that that would be crazy uh added
fan can we agree on that
i don't know final fantasy yeah i i
think uh i think we could see that
remake two i think square has a lot of
uh invested into
into into them you know my mic drop
moment is and i know everyone in the
chat about to disagree so
i think they're going to announce they
bought square enix
because stopping stepping real spooky
with them man they
like we ain't talking like one game like
they got a game made by
team ninja that that has the score
enoch's license
how'd that happen unless sony owns it
i mean you might have a point i saw i
saw that uh
exchange on twitter or would you come to
our world
or can you please come get us or
whatever they said i said oh god
i was like this is gonna be like i don't
know i feel like they were doing the
if this is true and they were doing all
these game passes of xbox
because they was trying to cash out
before they sell out so
like to me it just it makes sense like
they
they almost every final fantasy has been
exclusive at this point
seven remake two ironically we were
supposed to uh
that exclusivity was supposed to end in
six months
and then it stops ending and now it's
exclusive for another six months
like and it's like i said
with the whole scenario with team ninja
supposedly working on a neo-type game
with the final fantasy universe
why is scoring enix working with team
ninja
there's no reason for them to work
together but guess who does work with
team ninja
sony why would square let sony have
their license to let team ninja make a
game
unless sony owns it all like
i was gonna ask you what happened
because i haven't seen um
the new final fantasy on xbox i'm not
sure if it's there but i kind of was
waiting for it to come i was told
that it's not coming out for xbox series
that's crazy but i was told two years
ago it was coming out for xbox
so something changed and i think that
purchase changed
but but you know i'm a uh
here's a little spoiler thing i think
microsoft bought sega
so oh can we speak on that before we go
i mean i guess we can you know be crazy
persona 6 is announced at the xbox stage
and they bought them it's exclusive to
xbox oh
oh my god do you do you understand how
many people would be hurt hey listen i
got game pass already i'm straight
i ain't worried about it yo that's
that's gonna be wild
oh man no but um i literally hope that
sega
and you know microsoft you know join
forces
you know cause if you can read the tea
leaves you can read the tea leaves if
you look at the sonic blue controller
it's the actual
blue that sonic is it's the same hue um
i don't know if you remember but you saw
the uh the young lady who was at her
work desk with the uh
she on the sega work that's with all the
sonic paraphernalia and whatnot she did
she do up the x
come on y'all like them all i think it's
i i don't want to say i think it's a
safe bet i was uh was kicking away
something about it but all i'm saying is
stuff keeps happening ironically pushing
the needle more and more that way
you have stuff that's happening with
sega being part of sammy because
sammy to my knowledge sammy is the one
that's publicly traded not sega
and sammy owns sega
ironically sammy separates their
financial
records from sega why would you do that
unless you're about to sell that company
to someone
ironically because we know the pride of
japan
we know how they would feature we know
the kind of thought process that they
have
ironically they start scraping sega
logos off buildings that's been there
for years why would you do that
you get yakuza like a dragon exclusive
to the pla
the xbox series x for a couple months
before it comes out to playstation
why would you do that fantasy star is
exclusive to xbox
why would you do that and to my
knowledge we see
games like square enix's games coming
out of game pass
like uh kingdom hearts are about to come
out one of the final fantasies came out
has any of the yakuzas came out of game
pass hustle any of them
i don't think so none of them hey you
mean to tell me they got like a two-year
contract with them
everyone else got six months to a year
but but but
sega got two year one makes no sense
why is none of these games coming out of
game pass none of them
i don't know one game owned by sega
that's came out of game pass
but that's just me but anyway
any any more last words to to to the
audience before we take off
hustle well hey last words to you thank
you for joining for having me man
i really appreciate it um thank you for
having erica for the win that was super
dope because she had kind of had to
carry him through that kids conversation
um hey i dropped a new video um y'all
should go to my youtube channel and
check it out
yeah definitely go check out hustle's
video you can definitely put that in the
chat also
uh but uh i definitely appreciate it for
coming by we'll be here next week with
i'll probably have four people here
uh four including myself so we're going
to do that prediction show for microsoft
sunday is going to be iops we're having
some big guests on
you know uh who who's one i could throw
out
i i'm not doing i'm not getting in
trouble i ain't doing none of that so
definitely go there man i appreciate
everyone for coming through appreciate
all the likes all the super chats
appreciate all the viewership
until next time gaming addicts we're out
of here peace